vous la connaissez peut-être sous le nom
de jean mouro la célèbre plaignante
anonyme du jugement historique de la
cour suprême celui qui avait légalisé
l'avortement aux états unis en 1973 à 26
ans pour le bien de la cause
elle s'était révélée au grand public
normal me convient de son vrai nom
l'emblème du mouvement pro choix
amérique est pour une bonne partie des
années 80 jusqu'à ce qu'elle se
métamorphose à la surprise générale la
voici en 95 converti en militante de la
droite religieuse anti avortement jésus
lui a pardonné ses pesci disait à
l'époque le révérend qui l'a recruté on
la verra ensuite dans toutes les
manifestations côté dit puissant lobby
pro vie américain tenter de renverser
les droits qu'elle avait pourtant
garanti aux femmes
vingt ans plus tôt le nom de norma meco
vie dans une infolettre dans une demande
de financement en entraîner en fait une
augmentation des dons pour le mouvement
anti choix
la militante est décidé il ya trois ans
fidèle à ses convictions religieuses du
moins c'est ce que tout le monde croyait
[Musique]
sur son lit de mort mame cor vie est
passée vous avez et admet qu'elle a été
payée plus beaucoup en argent et en
cadeau par les évangélistes pour militer
contre les droits des femmes à
l'avortement s'étaient mutuelle j'ai
pris leur argent ils m'ont mis devant
les caméras et m'ont dit quoi dire et
c'est ce que je disais en révélations
sont au coeur d'un documentaire choc
intitulé alias chinois qui sera diffusée
vendredi sur la chaîne fx aux états unis
normal me raconte que son militantisme
pro vie était en fait un coup bien monté
la grande comédie pendant toutes ces
années effectivement de mettre de
l'avant ses stratégies moins orthodoxes
du mouvement anti choix car exploiter
des femmes qui ont changé de camp ou
encore qu'ils regrettent leur
appartement en demeure encore
aujourd'hui
une stratégie payante pour le mouvement
pro vie dit la chercheur à l'ifri en
citant l'exemple de la militante de
l'heure aux états unis abidjan 27 son
histoire porté au grand écran l'an
dernier dans le film controversé en inde
a été sévèrement critiquée et qualifié
de propagande par les questions choix
vraiment très de la base d'informations
vouloir pousser à l'enjeu sur le plan
moral mais avec des stratégiques font
humorale les documentaires temps
d'explorer qui était la vraie dream pas
mon parcours social complexe à l'image
du débat qui divise encore en 2020 le
peuple américain
ici tu as marre altérer ce coup
radio-canada morère